côté les maires en première ligne face
aux difficultés on l'a encore vu depuis
deux ans avec la crise qu vide ça
devient parfois difficile de trouver des
volontaires lors des dernières élections
municipales on a décompté une vingtaine
de communes sans aucun candidat et après
vous l'imaginez pour trouver un maire ça
peut prendre beaucoup de temps exemple à
trangé on est dans un village de l'indre
qui est resté plus d'un an sans conseil
municipal sagna de schirrhein
178 m et pas un seul candidat
après les élections municipales de 2020
le village du trajet s'est retrouvé sans
air sans aucun élu pour gérer le
quotidien des habitants
impossible pourtant de laisser le siège
totalement vacants la commune doit alors
être placé sous l'autorité d'une
délégation spéciale
contacté par le préfet l'amiral jouer
conseiller municipal d'une autre commune
de l'indre accepte d'endosser le rôle
ce retraité de la marine habite pourtant
à trois quarts d'heure de route dû
trancher on estime qu'il faut s'engager
pour la vie de la cité qu'il faut
s'engager pour faire vivre nos
territoires et je me voyais mal dire non
alors qu'à village était finalement sans
sens conseil municipal sans moyen de
sans moyens de vivre sans moyens de
s'assumer pendant un an et demi il
assure l'intérim
entouré de deux autres bénévoles
mais la délégation spéciale n'est pas
élu ces compétences sont donc limités
leur rôle c'est d'assurer la gestion des
affaires courantes et urgentes de la
commune elle n'a pas le pouvoir d'
investir elle n'a pas le pouvoir
d'engager les dépenses au delà de la
durée de son mandat sur le titre
d'exemple pendant le camion de la
commune le hic les rues je pourrais
remplacer la batterie mais pas changer
de véhicule une solution provisoire en
attendant de trouver un candidat
tous les trois mois de nouvelles
élections sont organisées mais le temps
passe et personne ne se présente les
habitants ont alors peur de voir le
transit fusionner avec une commune
voisine on perd l'indépendance de la
commune on perd son identité et je crois
pour la plupart des habitants ici et la
majorité veulent conserver voulait
conserver leur identité
propre
le salut viendra d'une nouvelle
habitante
alexandra beauvais nat et 27 ans a
quitté la région parisienne pour
s'installer ici au début de l'année 2020
face au désarroi des anciens elle décide
de se présenter est largement élu à la
tête d'une liste sans étiquette
politique
c'est vrai qu'au début ce n'était pas
forcément dans mes projets mais après
avoir parlé avec des habitants dans un
carnaval et larmes aux yeux que son
visage soit abandonnée carrément est un
qui a hésité à déménager
je fonctionne beaucoup avec le coeur en
fête la mission de la délégation
spéciale s'achève celle de la nouvelle
maire commence ça c'est ce que nous a
laissé la délégation a classé sachant
que j'en ai classe et une bonne partie
limitation de la vitesse sur les routes
odeur de la déchetterie voisine elle
s'empare très vite de ses premiers
dossier le plus urgent fait revenir des
commerces dans ce village qui n'en
compte plus aucun revenu tous les pains
blancs geler tous les depuis quelques
années un épicier qui passe qui fait
qui peut
c'est possible passe encore
organisatrice de mariage elle n'a aucune
expérience en politique il faudra
apprendre sur le tas globalement pas
peur sachant que pas mal d'habitants
peuvent m'aider ils m'ont tous dit on
est derrière toi même si on fait pas
partie du conseil si tu as des questions
on est là bonjour pas pourquoi on
devrait
devrait en faire toute une montagne
sachant qu'on n'est jamais tout seul et
que c'était bien un mais critères pour
présenter je veux pas être tout seul
comme elle la plupart des membres de son
équipe municipale sont des novices en
politique et les anciens s'en
réjouissent après plus d'un an et demi
sans mère ce sont les jeunes qui ont
sauvé la mairie du village
ce sont les jeunes qui ont sauvé la
mairie du village voilà un message
d'optimisme et d'espoir pour lancer un
débat qui démarre sur une note plutôt
pessimiste mère fatigué démocratie en
danger voilà le le titre que l'on a
choisi pour ce débat je vous présente
mes invités cécile gallien bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes maire de vorey sur
arzon en haute-loire et vice présidente
de l'association des maires de france
stéphane le foll bonsoir et bienvenue
soit le maire du mans président le monde
éprouve métropole vous publiez renouer
avec la france des lumières c'est chez
calmann-lévy martial foucault bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi directeur du
cevipof vous publiez mer au bord de la
crise de nerfs la démocratie locale
peut-elle survivre c'est aux éditions de
l'aube et l'éthicien accrue pas toujours
à mes côtés je commence avec vous
martial foucault peut-être pour un un
constat après avoir vu ce reportage dé
des communes sans mère après les
municipales est ce que ces nouveaux ou
est-ce que ça a toujours existé
non c'est pas nouveau c'est un phénomène
qui a toujours existé autour autour
d'une soixantaine 50 à une soixantaine
donc ce n'est pas un phénomène sur
lequel on devrait être en alerte en
revanche il traduit peut-être un sujet
oui où il n'y a pas consensus c'est vrai
qu'on peut s'interroger ce qui est une
crise de vocation est ce que
l'engagement municipal aujourd'hui et
est en déperdition oui moi je disais
tout à l'heure en titre pardon vous
interrompre que 30 % des maires opposés
aux dernières élections municipales
n'était pas candidat à leur réélection
là aussi est ce que c'est le symbole
d'une crise de vocation est ce que
comment vous l'analysez nombre je dirais
le contraire c'est plutôt un signe
d'engagement réel vous savez on est le
seul pays en europe qui peut se targuer
de mobiliser pour une élection un
million de candidats
on est le seul pays non on peut parler
de crise de la démocratie locale mais
mine de rien cinq cent mille élus un
conseillers municipaux élus donc un
million de candidats c'est unique en
europe non on voit bien que c'est
l'effet du nombre de communes qui
appellent cet engagement mais on
pourrait avoir des centaines ou des
milliers de communes sans candidat donc
aujourd'hui encore une vitalité
démocratique au plan local ensuite
est-ce que cette situation est
finalement un palliatif à une réflexion
sur l'état de la démocratie locale on
voit bien que il ya un vrai sujet à
peine 5% des conseillers municipaux et
des moeurs sont âgés de moins de 30 ans
une très très faible féminisation et
puis aussi la jeune mère qu'on a vu
c'est presque le contre-exemple quoi oui
c'est le contre exemple c'est 20% des
moeurs aujourd'hui sont des femmes alors
c'est un peu plus élevé dans les
conseils municipaux parce qu'on atteint
prés 37% là où je pense qu'il ya une
inquiétude sur l'état de la démocratie
locale c'est davantage géré sur la
trajectoire on voit bien que devenir
meurt il ya des étapes un engagement
associatif souvent puis ensuite une
première de fonctions de conseiller
municipal et je crois que tout cela
amène finalement à prendre des fonctions
à l'âge moyen ses 59 ans aujourd'hui
demeure donc on pourrait peut-être
imaginer une inclusion beaucoup plus
prématurée d'une partie de la population
à ces fonctions de consignes alors voilà
pour le pour le constat je voudrais
avoir votre retour d'expérience à à l'un
et à l'autre stéphane le foll je
commence avec vous tous sur sur l'état
de la démocratie de notre démocratie
locale est ce que vous la trouvez
fatigués ou est ce que finalement vous
vous accrochez à l'espoir de jeunes
comme comme cette jeune femme qui qui
prennent à bras le corps un nouveau
dessin politique ont d'abord aujourd hui
rappeler que j'ai été élu à 23 ans dans
un village de 256 habitants et j'ai été
conseiller municipal de son village
temps 12 ans et mon père en est devenu
maire après dans un évier 23 ans grande
jeunesse en l'engageant de jeunesse
j'ai participé j'ai été un élu pendant
ses douze années qui était effectivement
dans la vie des villages c'est parce que
ces délits soit enrayée lennon et ça l'a
été au deuxième tour j'ai avec un copain
et lui est pas passé moi je suis passé
mais j'ai des copains mais produit bien
sûr toujours avec
j'étais lui je souviens
dixième sur 11 et après j'étais très
fier ce deuxième mandat je suis j'ai
fini troisième parce que tous calculs ou
non de devoir et j'étais arrivé juste
derrière le maire sortant et puis
l'agriculture du village qui faisait
bien sûr l'unanimité bon bref pour vous
dire que moi je pense que au delà de la
question de la démocratie locale c'est
la question de démocratie représentative
qui est posée aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt ça a quel sujet mais vous
avez évoqué mon livre si vite que ça que
je pense alors on ramène ça à chaque
élection en disant est ce que pour les
conseils régionaux il ya un problème
démocratique est ce que pour les mères
et un problème des mots canadien
problèmes de dettes démocratie
représentative et ça c'est une question
beaucoup plus importante qu'on ne le
pense aujourd'hui en france et à chaque
fois que dans le débat on essaye de
considérer qu'on pourrait prendre des
décisions ailleurs que là où il ya des
élus qui ont été élus pour le faire
lorsque on crée des conventions
citoyenne je vais évoquer sa une fois en
plaisantant à peine si on peut réunir
150 citoyens qui décident pratiquement
de la loi à la place des députés la
question qui est posée ensuite c'est
pourquoi dira des députés donc il ya
tout un débat à avoir sur l'organisation
de démocratie à la fois sur la question
de la démocratie participative et la
participation citoyenne mais aussi sur
la démocratie représentative et si la
démocratie a un sens me semble-t-il
c'est masquer les des représentative
sinon on est dans des formes différentes
et c'est plutôt ça le sujet et donc les
maires les communes et on le voit
d'ailleurs sur les taux de participation
sur les communes rurales y ait beaucoup
plus de participation que sur les
grandes métropoles on a donc un effet
nationale qui joue plus sur les grands
zones urbaines que dans les zones
rurales que j'ai connu et bien connu on
voilà donc moi je pense que au delà de
la question des mères
fatigué ou en colère c'est vrai que
c'est difficile c'est envahi on va y
revenir sur les réunions 6 peuvent se
conclure le travail des mères bien bien
bien compris cécile gallien c'est votre
troisième mandat oui il ya eu voilà des
des moments et peut-être plusieurs je ne
sais pas où vous vous êtes dit mais je
vais je vais pas rempiler c'est trop
c'est trop finalement de charge de
charge mentale de boulot qui se
surajoutent les uns aux autres alors
déjà je vais répondre à la première
question je ne permettez moi j'ai monté
une liste en 2008 parce qu'il fallait
que ça change le l'ancien maire était là
depuis longtemps la commune était
endetté je suis maire du en bourse entre
2500 habitants appelés je voulais que
des femmes que des jeunes aussi puissent
faire partie d'une d'une équipe
municipale nous étions trois listes à
concourir nous avons toujours été trois
ou deux listes à concourir j'ai fait ça
aussi parce que j'estimais qu'il fallait
plus de représentativité
voilà y'a autant d'habitants que
d'habitants dans dans les communes même
les communes rurales et puis je suis une
militante de la ruralité et j'ai fait
des études de développement des
territoires c'est ma passion
développement durable et je me suis dit
ben allez chiche on va aller voir on va
monter une équipe hyper complémentaire
très fin très expérimenté quasiment
jamais élu et on va aller voir si les
habitants nous font confiance soit là et
ils nous ont fait confiance et en ce qui
me concerne ça fait 13 ans que ça dure
les crises successives entre la crise
économique de 2008 la crise on va dire
social de des gilet jaune que j'ai vécu
dans ma chère puisque par trois fois je
me suis fait agresser quand même mais au
delà et la crise sanitaire aujourd'hui
nous les maires nous sommes comment dire
les facilitateurs les chefs d'orchestre
de ces petites république que sont
chacune des communes de france est elle
est là la richesse et nous sommes tous
en grande grande majorité républicains
amoureux de cette république française
amoureux de ses valeurs alors aussi je
suis fort je suis là
oui c'est pas possible mais oui alors au
bout d'un moment c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup de sacrifices mais beaucoup
voilà la vie de famille en prend un coup
voilà mes mais c'est tellement
enrichissant et je conseille à tous les
français toutes les françaises d'un jour
de concourir d'aller sur une liste aux
élections vraiment vous changez vous
changez vous changez votre commune et
vous vous changez aussi vous êtes un
parmi tous ces citoyens et vous êtes
aussi un petit peu le chef d'orchestre
de tout ça pour des communes vivent et
alors là j'ai une question comment faire
pour qu'il y ait plus de femmes c'est à
dire que vous parlez de démocratie
représentative et bien sûr je réagis
parce que je suis une femme bien sûr
mais c'est vrai que est représentée
continuellement au niveau de la ville
donc avec ce lien direct par des hommes
c'est quand même problématique qu'est ce
qui bloque et qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour que des femmes puissent
accéder à cette fonction doit juste
rappeler qu'il ya des femmes si je
prends lille martine aubry 20 portion
rennes nathalie a péri le style facile
pour sa viande est accordée il ya donc
il faut continuer à développer mais
dites pas que ce que non mais c'est pas
pour payer 50 50 oui 50/50 donc il faut
sûrement progresser je vous rappelle que
sur les grandes agglos c'est pas le cas
dans les communes de moins de 3500
habitants les listes sont paritaires
totalement paritaire mois que ce soit à
la ville ou à la métropole on est sur
des binômes avec une première adjointe
bien sûr qu'il faut progresser
qu'en fait c'est pas cgc pas jugement
ces jeux je pose la question pourquoi ça
bloque parce que faty surnom de loin les
lois sur la parité les listes qui ont
été engagés font cojo j'ai un engagement
que de plus en plus important vous
parliez d'expérience et pourquoi on
pourrait pas remonter plus tôt vous
faire en sorte que des gens prennent des
responsabilités plutôt ça vaut en
particulier pour les femmes et ça c'est
un vrai sujet donc tout ça c'est un
processus qui doit se mettre qui
s'enclenche qui est enclenchée qu'ils
vont poursuivre et qu'il faut bien sûr y
a une chose est l'échangé je me permets
une chose qui a fait changer et effet
qui ait plus de femmes qui sont élus au
jour d'aujourd'hui en france c'est les
lois sur la parité elle existe dans les
régions dans les départements
rappelez-vous se bidonne binôme fameux
binôme d'ailleurs si on n'avait pas
autant de conseillère départementale on
aurait peut-être moins de mer ça serait
intéressant de voir ce qu'il en est et
dans les communes de plus de 1000 il ya
une obligation de liste paraît terme et
dans les communes de moins de 1000
aucune obligation 80 % des communes de
france en moins de 1000 habitants bon
sang de bonsoir est-ce qu'il suffit que
le législateur légifère il ya un projet
de loi qui vient d'être posée par elodie
jacquet la forge une députée pour que en
2026 dans tous les communes dans toutes
les communes de francs
ses pairs au pays de marianne bon sang
de bonsoir et se compose privé de la
moitié de la population française je
pense pas j'ai rappelé les chiffres
c'est d'ailleurs une enquête du cevipof
20% effectivement des maires sont des
femmes l'âge moyen vous l'avez donné
tout à l'heure ses 59 ans 39% sont des
retraités 21 % sont des cadres c'est
quand même préoccupant sa martial
foucault ce décalage entre les mères
d'aujourd'hui c'était pièces de de
portrait robot du du maire français et
puis la société française dans son
ensemble oui peut-être de réaction sur
la question de la féminisation mais je
pense que attention parce que on peut
installer une loi dans la parité sur des
candidatures mais n'oublions pas ce qui
est vrai pour les élections
départementales à la tête des
départements vous n'avez pas l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes à la tête
des exécutifs et encore aujourd'hui une
majorité de présidents de départements
donc pour les élections municipales oui
allons dans cette direction je pense que
effectivement le retard est considérable
mais il faudrait également se soucier de
qui est à la tête de l'exécutif parce
que l'on parle des communes si on
regarde les intercommunalités la
situation elle est tout aussi
préoccupante c'est à dire que les chefs
d'exécutifs sont principalement
aujourd'hui des hommes à la tête des
intercommunalités quand bien même il ya
eu un effort et je vous rejoins vous
êtes je suis tout à fait d'accord on
commence à voir les effets de la parité
on commence à voir ses effets ensuite
sur ce que ce que vous évoquez par
rapport à la représentation on va dire
socialisation professionnelle des mères
c'est vrai que ça pose la question de la
démocratie représentative parce que dans
l'esprit de beaucoup de français la
démocratie représentative c'est l'idée
d'une démocratie certains théoriciens
appellent appelle ça une démocratie
descriptive c'est à dire que elle doit
être au miroir de ce qu'est le portrait
socio professionnelles
sociodémographiques d'un pays alors
effectivement avec ces chiffres on n'a
pas 40 % de retraités mais nous avons 40
% de mère retraitée nous avons également
10% fin 11% si je suis prêt si demers
agriculteurs les agriculteurs ne
représente aujourd'hui 1 % 2 la
population active donc on voit bien
qu'il ya un vrai sujet sur la démocratie
représentative mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire la démocratie représentative
les français ne font pas leurs proches
d'accorder par délégation leur pouvoir à
un maire qu'ils soient retraités qu'ils
soient commerçants ou qu'ils soient
agriculteurs c'est pas le sujet la
question qui se pose c'est est-ce que ce
maire va représenter les intérêts de la
commune premièrement est-ce que ce maire
est visible donc est-ce qu'il est
accessible et c'est quand même une des
qualités attendues d'un maire dans notre
enquête on voit ça depuis 2018
premièrement il ya une éthique de la
fonction être exemplaire l'honnêteté
être capable de finalement de mettre en
oeuvre les promesses énoncées puis la
deuxième la deuxième qualité attendue
d'un maire c'est vraiment
l'accessibilité c'est cette proximité
alors parfois on exagère en disant tout
se passe par la proximité mais non la
proximité veut dire qu'aujourd'hui si on
lâche un peu de lest sur cette question
là alors on va se retrouver avec des
citoyens qui n'auront comme voie
d'expression comme exutoire uniquement
le pouvoir national et donc c'est ça la
force finalement de ce maillage
territorial avec des élus qui sont
peut-être aujourd'hui avec des
compétences en deçà de ceux qui
devraient disposer mai mais attention ne
pensons pas qu en donnant plus de
compétences aux municipalités on va
régler le problème de la démocratie
représentative
alors vous avez parlé des
intercommunalités ça c'est un effet de
la loi un autre qui a été votée en en
2015 qui transfère une partie des
compétences des maires au aux
intercommunalités justement est ce que
vous y voyez
le point de départ d'un malaise des mers
et puis après je demanderai votre retour
d'expérience à l'autre martial foucault
moi j'ai coutume de dire que les maires
sont un peu comme comme les compressions
du sculpteur césar c'est dire qu'ils
sont ils sont à la fois pris en tenaille
par un état de plus en plus présent on
parle beaucoup de la recentralisation de
l'état ils sont pris en tenaille aussi
par des intercommunalités de plus en
plus omnipotente et et aussi des
citoyens de plus en plus exigeants alors
quand je le dis quand je dis comme ça et
une formule finalement une forme de
provocation mais l'intercommunalité est
un vrai sujet est un vrai sujet avec un
vrai paradoxe le paradoxe est le suivant
bien sûr beaucoup de maires ont témoigné
de leur insatisfaction du périmètre des
intercommunalités
mais en même temps quand on les
interroge quand je les rencontre très
peu d'entre eux sont prêts à faire
marche arrière à revenir sur ce qui a
été fait donc ils apprennent ils
apprennent investi structure aujourd'hui
un vrai sujet qui est moi je ne cesse de
rappeler les intercommunalités donc ces
établissements cep séisme selon
l'acronyme sont au service des communes
et aujourd'hui il ya un vrai j'ai acquis
un vrai débat où il ya une vraie tension
on laisse entendre que les
intercommunalités dont la légitimité
démocratique est un vrai sujet parce que
suffrage universel indirect c'est quand
même une curiosité dans notre pays qui
connaît quand même un certain nombre de
tensions démocratique donc installer des
élus de façon indirecte pause pour moi
un vrai défi démocratique donc que les
maires soient en tension pas en
compétition mais en tension avec
certaines certaines intercommunalités
oui c'est un sujet sur lequel il faudra
quand même un jour clarifier les choses
peut-être attention à certaines dérives
stéphane le foll c'est une réforme qui a
été portée par françois hollande avait
été son ministre de l'agriculture
pendant cinq ans si je ne me trompe pas
est ce qu avec le recul vous dit que
c'est une bonne réforme ou qu'il faut la
toile était la modifier
la question qui est posée c'est les
moyens qu'on donne aux corinne pour
pouvoir exercer les compétences que les
citoyens de monde mais est on le sait
fut un temps la multiplication de
certains investissements faisait qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'argent qui pouvait être
dépensée mais pas forcément pour
répondre à des besoins structurants si
vous prenez la question d'une piscine
dans un milieu rural pas simple de
financer et de faire fonctionner une
piscine se regrouper et avoir à
l'échelle d'une intercommunalité une
piscine ça peut s'envisager et ça peut
se gérer donc la question qui est posée
c'est qu'elle est le lieu et le moyen
qu'on se donne pour assumer des
investissements qui sont structurants et
indispensables seront les questions de
la santé je prends les questions de la
mobilité jetons maintenant mais ça on
voit bien le principe le principe il est
il est clair et il est de bon sens mais
après si l'intercommunalité prend trop
de pouvoirs ou mail à sa main sur les
gèrent les intercommunales parce que
vouloir régler les problèmes uniquement
par les règles qu'on va se fixer de
manière collective ça oublie que chacun
a sa responsabilité dans la manière dont
il gère son intercommunalité moi je
alors après je ne vais pas parler au nom
des maires qui sont à l'échelle de la
métropole je suis aussi président de la
métropole président du pays je voyais
voilà j'essaye de faire en sorte que
justement le débat que nous avons dans
le cadre des collèges des maires des
séminaires des mères c'est justement
pour faire en sorte que
l'intercommunalité par rapport aux
moyens qu'elle peut apporter soit au
service de ce que demandent les maires
et on en discute ensemble donc il ya
aussi une manière de gouverner qui nous
si importante que les règles qu'on va se
fixer juste un dernier point sur la
question du suffrage indirect
alors allons jusqu'au bout de la logique
inverse qui consisterait à avoir un
président ou une présidente de métropole
élu au suffrage direct alors à ce moment
là le pouvoir des maires puisque si à
l'échelle d'une intercommunalité l'un
d'entre eux est élu au suffrage
universel à l'échelle de
l'intercommunalité
je vous laisse imaginer le rapport de
force en terme de pouvoir entre celui
qui a la totalité de l'électorat de
l'intercommunalité celui qui à celui de
la sa commune donc attention aussi à ses
formes de facilité qui consiste à faire
que l'intercommunalité est un problème
parce que si on va jusqu'au bout de sa
logique là à ce moment là alors le
risque ce jeune artiste
les
collégiens là-dessus qu'est ce qui
change là on est vraiment dans votre
retour d'expérience aussi avec les
intercommunalités pour vous on est passé
de
d'intercommunalité de 10 20 communes
souvent des communautés de communes
ensuite à des agglos quinon qui ont des
compétences obligatoires c'est à dire
qu'on est passé quelque part de
d'intercommunalité souhaité voulu entre
voisins à des intercommunalités qui ont
raflé énormément de compétences
alors quand la gay alors qui c'est quoi
les faits les fesses alors par exemple
en prise avec le terrain peu trop
technocratique quelques ailes lacunes ou
quelle dérive où vous pointez le
développement économique ça c'était déjà
le cas mais tout ce qui est mobilité eau
et assainissement de choses de la vie
les ordures ménagères un certain nombre
de choses qui avant et pouvait être
traité au niveau des syndicats
intercommunaux qui parfois fonction
fonctionne assez bien il ya eu des
grosses machines parfois pas partout en
france des grosses intercours des
grosses communautés d'agglo xxl qui ont
été créés avec un mal être un mal être
des mères écouter les maires notamment
des communes plutôt rural danse et
interco une historie nice ne s'y
retrouvent pas mais vous l'avez vous
avez raison de le dire tout est question
de gouvernance si les membres enfin
l'eee si les élus dans ces exécutifs
interco considère
égalitairement chacun des maires qui
siègent bien sûr dans ces
intercommunalités après tout qui a été
élu vous disiez très bien il ya des
mandats communaux les gens ont choisi
leur mère et leur équipe municipale pour
un mandat pour un projet ces projets
doivent être intégrés quelque part aidé
par les intercommunalités tout est
question de gouvernance soit c'est une
gouvernance à l'ecoute des communes soit
ça ne l'est pas il ya des choses qui
marche formidablement bien en gros
interco d'autres où c'est pas du tout le
cas alors la loi engagement et proximité
heureusement qui est arrivé en 2010 9,1
un petit peu obligé des conseils de mer
un certain nombre de choses dans quel
normalement les communes soient sont
tout écouté et pris en considération
le chemin est donc moi il le chemin est
long marcel fukuyama rajouter un mot
là-dessus oui je sais pas si on peut
aujourd'hui tranché par une nouvelle loi
je crois que la situation des pannes
n'est pas propice à une nouvelle loi
pour détricoter ce qui a été vécu comme
un mauvais tricot donc en revanche
l'apprentissage sur les règles de
gouvernance oui ça c'est un sujet encore
une fois je j'ignore véritablement les
vertus d'une loi pour faciliter la
gouvernance parce que moi je fais partie
de ces de ces personnes qui croit
beaucoup aux institutions et donc quand
on définit l'institution il s'agit de
donner un cadre et ensuite chacun doit
s'approprier ce cadre aujourd'hui les
institutions elles sont faites de telle
sorte que effectivement on n'a pas une
culture politique dans ce pays 2
j'allais dire de coalition et c'est un
sujet que l'on peut déplacer au plan
national mais ce que vous évoquez si on
a effectivement une intercommunalité à
40 50 communes on n'est pas très loin de
la moyenne en france et que vous avez
des logiques partisanes qui sont pas
toujours présente mais il faut quand
même les avoir à l'esprit il peut y
avoir des logiques partisanes dans des
intercommunalités
bon et bien demandé à des maires de
travailler de manière coordonnée même si
on a coutume de dire les enjeux ne sont
pas partisans hymne au risque à des
logiques partisanes et que quand on
parle sur un certain nombre de
compétences c'est pas la même chose
d'être de droite et de gauche est donc
cette culture de la du gouvernement de
coalition même au plan intercommunal
elle n'est pas prête parce qu'on n'a pas
cette culture de gouvernement en france
et pas simplement au plan local mais
c'est une culture politique qui n'est
pas propre à notre notre pays les maires
qui sont les élus préférés des français
il faut le rappeler 65% des français
selon le baromètre de la confiance
politique du cevipof de février dernier
65% des personnes interrogées font
confiance alors à leur mère mais mais
les maires sont aussi en première ligne
face à la violence l'an dernier près de
1300 agressions menaces on insulte
recenser ces trois fois plus qu'en 2019
un exemple en côte d'or où les
incivilités envers les mères se
multiplient pour y répondre la mf et la
gendarmerie nationale propose des
formations spécifiques jérémy huntsman
et gaspard flamand
ce dimanche 2 mai 2021 jean-claude
girard s'en souvient comme si c'était
hier ils se promènent le long du canal
de bourgogne lorsqu'un pilote de quad
déboule sur la piste cyclable
je lui dis il faut pas rouler comme ça
dans la commune c'est dangereux il ya
des preneurs il ya des enfants c'est pas
raisonnable le pilote me dis tout de
suite mais qui tu es toi pour me parler
comme ça et quand je lui dis je lis
maire de la commune responsable de la
tranquillité publique la seule réponse
que j'ai c'est j'en ai rien à je
descends je te casse la gueule la
situation s'envenime et plusieurs
individus s'en prennent à lui j'entends
quelqu'un dire fait le ter celui là et
où je prends un coin de manière certaine
un coup de pied au niveau du thorax et
un coup de barre derrière la tête et je
perd connaissance aujourd'hui neuf
personnes sont mises en examen pour
cette violente agression qui a laissé
des traces chez l'élu si je suis amené à
croiser un groupe que ce soit dans un
centre commercial dans la rue j'ai une
vraie appréhension j'ai peur de me faire
agresser c'était quelque chose que je
n'avais jamais connu mais que j'aurais
peut-être à tort ou pas jamais imaginé
qu'ils puissent que ça puisse être rivés
sur sur la commune
pour faire face à ce type d'agressions
et d'incivilités envers les mères des
formations sont organisées dans le
département depuis plusieurs mois elle
vise à donner aux élus des clés pour
désamorcer les conflits
crayon mais non maintenant je veux oui
ah ben non il va falloir l'étranger
attentivement dans cet exercice cette
mère doit échanger avec un habitant sur
les nerfs progressivement elle parvient
à calmer son administré à vous savez moi
aussi j'ai divorcé donc c'est pas facile
vous savez bien bah oui c'est pourquoi
je
bien moi il faut à tout prix je leur
fasse faire des activités parce que je
suis pas savoir m'occuper grâce aux
techniques enseignées par deux
négociateurs formés au gign on est là
pour l'écouter on l'a dit au début il
cède les coudes beaucoup des coûts donc
faut qu'on allait vous parlez on la
laisse on la laisse dire ce qu'elle a à
dire et ensuite
quand ça va descendre on peut parler
fait c'est pas une formation de
self-défense on va leur apprendre déjà à
s'adapter à leurs interlocuteurs avoir
une distance de communication
raisonnable essayez un petit peu de
de se synchroniser avec la personne être
en phase avec la personne avec qui on
communique
on va vous trouver des solutions
altercation avec des commerçants
problème d'internet les mises en
situation sont nombreuses et rassure ses
élus de petites communes souvent en
première ligne sors dehors
on l'a tout de suite des gens qui l'ont
acquis qui peut qui savent où nous
trouver s'il ya quelque chose à savoir
la j'ai quand même eu quelques
conflits à désamorcer
des outils qui vont être bien utile pour
désamorcer des situations qui peuvent
nous arrivait assez régulièrement dans
le département ces formations se
multiplient grâce au travail de
l'association des maires de france qui
juge cet outil désormais indispensable
quelqu'un qui est volontaire pour être
maire il n'est pas volontaire pour ça
que se faire casser la figure il est
volontaire pour être au service de ses
administrés il faut qu'on crée des
situations je pense que c'est le cas
pour que les mères les femmes et les
hommes qui s'engagent pour leur commune
puisse le faire d'une manière totalement
ce raid en côte d'or un maire sur dix a
déjà été formés à la gestion des
conflits
cécile gallien vous avez subi cette
violence dans quelles circonstances
moi c'était durant la crise et gilet
jaune voilà je suis politiquement
marqués et en retour nous ne sommes pas
très nombreux il fallait aller trouver
quelqu'un et c'était moi donc visite de
motards c'était en novembre
ensuite il fait la préfecture un joli
message sexiste et légèrement menaçant
sur la mairie pour fêter me souhaiter la
bonne année et puis six jours après
c'était car enfin 25 voitures aux portes
de la maison en pleine nuit donc si vous
voulez mois après je m'engage je sais
c'est pas facile à vivre parce que si
les agressions ont quand même alors j'ai
porté plainte bon il ya eu un rappel à
l'ordre bon voilà en plus je connaissais
certains pas tous mais bon voilà ça
c'est plutôt bien fini mon compagnon
étant terriblement calme et à gérer la
situation donc
mais je dois dire que ça vous laisse pas
tout à fait
voilà vous n'êtes plus là même avant
qu'après par contre ce que j'ai voulu
absolument faire c'est que les gens dans
leur diversité se reparle parce que même
dans nos communes rurales que ce soit
les retraités les jeunes les ouvriers
les femmes seules les enfin il ya il y
avait ce besoin il ya ce besoin entre
générations entre personnes de
conditions différentes de se reparler
parce que je suis pas sûr qu'au comptoir
du village du bar du village les gens se
parlent et se parle sur le fond et donc
moi j'ai après j'ai organisé deux grands
débats je me suis assis dans la salle
joue vers la salle polyvalente
c'est mes adjoints qui ont géré et il
s'est passé des moments merveilleux où
les anciens demandé aux jeunes mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez le référendum
machin comment vous voyez les choses là
le partage des richesses enfin les
questions écologiques et les anciens
disent en on a connu les référendum on à
machin voilà est en fait les les jeunes
sont sortis de ce ces grands débats en
dix ans on a 30 ans on ne nous a jamais
entendu on n'a jamais appris autant de
choses que ce soit en l'espace de deux
heures et demie ou dans la sincérité des
propos entre les générations sur des
sujets libres les gens ont pu sans
s'invectiver donner leur avis échanger
et se faire progresser mutuellement les
uns les autres voilà moi mon job en tant
que maire c'est la cohésion sociale
territoriale et lutter contre les
fractures
c'est aussi ça c'est est ce que vous
direz que c'est parce que vous avez
réussi justement en organisant ces
grands débats à transformer cette cette
violence en dialogue que vous êtes dis
je je rempile je me présente de nouveau
ce que j'imagine que au soir d'une
agression doit se dire je j'arrête quoi
peut-on oui mais justement je danse et
vous savez c'est dans la difficulté des
fois qu'on trouve la force de de se dire
mais non la commune enfin les communes
de retrouver de l'apaisement il faut
aider les gens qui sont dans la
difficulté
on peut passer en arrêter là voyez donc
voilà puis avec une équipe
l'objectif d'un maire je pense que c'est
de faire en sorte que sont sa commune
elle reste vivante elle le soit de plus
en plus est avec le co vie dans la
chance d'accueillir énormément
d'habitants qui choisissent la campagne
pour venir habiter chez nous on est ravi
donc voilà donc les chaussées des
changes les crises passent les choses
changent nos anciens ils ont connu des
guerres ils ont aussi su gérer
difficilement mais il ya eu déjà eu des
lendemains heureux
au sortir des guerres ou des crises donc
voilà stéphane le foll a on dit souvent
que le maire c1 et lui apporter
d'engueulades est ce que c'est vrai
aussi pour un maire d'une grande ville
en avant j'ai jamais aimé ses
expressions porter dans le gala de
porter de baffes ce que justement on
alimente cette idée que parce que c'est
la proximité pour revenir 1 l'idée de
départ tout est permis je crois qu'il
faut remettre un peu de règles et le
respect ça existe et je reviens sur la
question de la démocratie représentative
à force de laisser penser que tout est
possible et au nom de la proximité tout
est possible un soin tout est possible
alors les maires sont confrontés vous
l'avez très bien dit on est tous
confrontés
c'est vrai aussi quand on quand on est
l'élu d'une grande ville avec évidemment
les plus nombreuses
moi j'étais ministre j'habite au mont et
un soir un dimanche soir des
agriculteurs étaient venus chez moi un
bon et ça c'est pas très bien passée
c'était pas si facile j'ai été maire
j'ai eu une crise d'arrêter forains pour
une histoire de de fête foraine qui
devaient être déplacés c'était très mal
passé aussi on est confronté quelquefois
des gens ça a été montré qu'ils
n'acceptent pas telle ou telle décision
dont on connaît toujours et c'est
d'autant plus fort que notre société et
les individus qui la composent porte
aussi en eux mêmes beaucoup de
contradictions dans leur désir et comme
ils peuvent pas quelquefois les gérer il
reporte sur l'élu qui doit les gérer
pour eux pas facile de faire ça on prend
les discussions qu'on a sur plein de
domaines sur l'énergie tout le monde est
pour les énergies renouvelables mais
quand il y a des l'arrière vous avez
tous ces sujets là vers qui reviennent
mais celui qui est censé représenter et
prendre la décision au nom de l'intérêt
général mais quand ça coince quand ils
n'y arrivent pas et quand il ya des gens
qui refusent tel ou tel choix hôtel
était de décision là ça devient
compliqué donc il faut éviter les
formules que vous avez évoqué terme et
étaient elles ont été répétés vous
remettre un peu de respect
ce cette fonction qui consiste et que
vous l'avez rappelé à être aussi forme
de médiateur intermédiaires et de porter
des choix avait essayé de faire
comprendre les faire adhérer peut pas y
arriver pour tout le monde mérite du
respect on doit d'accord et on peut bien
entendu ne s'est pas forcément las vegas
c'est pas la violence la discussion ça
ne peut pas être la violence et on a
intérêt de le répéter parce que à force
de dire que tout est possible et
qu'après tout il est colère qui
s'exprime doigts pour aller jusqu'au
bout faut passer mais c'est une
dimension importante marcel foucault
parce que c'est aussi une soupape d'une
certaine façon dans une dans une
démocratie la possibilité d'aller voir
un élu pour lui dire ça ça ne me plaît
pas évidemment dans le respect
oui on peut dire que c'est un signe de
bonne vitalité de la démocratie mais je
suis pas certain que les élus aient
envie tous les jours d'être confronté à
des violences
symboliques je parle de de discussion de
voilà de huy l'élimination je demande
pas la violence évidemment non mais
parfois moi j'insiste beaucoup sur les
violences symboliques parce que ça peut
être là on parle d'un cas extrêmes
d'agression mais parfois c'est de
l'intimidation et ça c'est beaucoup plus
subtil et quand on est maire on n'est
pas forcément prêt à gérer on n'est pas
chaque maire n'est pas un médiateur
social ou une médiatrice sociale
pars pars formation donc moi ce qui me
paraît peut-être le plus important c'est
les causes vont réfléchir sur les causes
et je crois que ce que vous dites en
commun un phénomène
sur le fun vous parlez de respect qui a
effectivement une sorte de déliquescence
d'un respect d'un jardin d'un bien
commun moi je vois quelque chose de plus
frappants auxerre pendant pendant près
de 40 ans on a vu la montée de
l'individualisation dans des
comportements privés ac de consommation
on a offert la possibilité que chaque
décision devait être individuel et
c'était ça la clé du bonheur individuel
et maintenance est en train de se
transposer dans la sphère publique et
donc gros plan que mes citoyens
consommateurs alors à la fois citoyen
consommateur ça c'est une dimension mais
aussi citoyens qui ont un rapport de
plus en plus individuelle à la chose
publique donc c'est je suis contribuable
donc j'ai droit à c'est aussi le citoyen
et faut voir aussi des transformations
dans les territoires avec beaucoup de
mobilité et donc vous avez des nouveaux
résidents qui arrivent et qui ne sont
pas à culture et à la vie d'une dune
d'une collectivité et qui produisent
effectivement ces phénomènes de plus en
plus individuelle moi je me souviens de
cette histoire racontée par par
l'historien le goff qui parlait de ce
village de cadenet en dix ans mais qui a
donné ces c'est le village car postal
tant que l'on peut rencontrer des gens
au bar au troc est en train de boire
l'apéritif tout va bien mais demandez
aux nouveaux résidents de se mettre au
diapason de cette vie collective alors
là c'est terminé chacun reste dans son
pavillon avec une haie de troènes bien
vert et la piscine en devenir donc vous
voyez ce rapport de plus en plus
individuelle aujourd'hui est un élément
qui provoque ces réactions ou bien sûr
le respect n'est pas présent mais aussi
une demande instantanée je ne suis pas
satisfait je demande une réponse
individuelle mais alors il ya une autre
forme de pression va pas les comparer là
aussi sur les mers c'est la course au
haut parrainage
laetitia les candidats présidentiels
comme d'habitude les extrêmes se
plaignent de la difficulté à les obtenir
stratégie de com est-ce que c'est une
stratégie comme une réalité bah écoutez
c'est une réalité pour les petits
candidats apparemment nicolas dupont
aignan dit que depuis cet été il fait
deux déplacements par semaine il se rend
lui-même dans les mairies pour tenter de
convaincre les maires de le parrainer
florian philippot arrosent les maires de
courrier mais il ya aussi des
personnalités de premier ordre jean luc
mélenchon je vous rappelle qu'il avait
fait quand même un score très honorable
en 2017 et lui même dit qu'il a des
problèmes à récolter ses parrainages
comme eric zemmour bien qu'il ne soit
pas encore candidat en tout cas son
équipe fait savoir puisque c'est un de
ses membres à des membres de son équipe
qu'il a dit au figaro que de 600
personnes sont en train de récolter les
parrainages là en ce moment en france
donc c'est une grosse opération pour
eric zemmour qu'il est longue pas encore
candidat et marine le pen comme
d'habitude se plaint on commence à avoir
l'habitude il me semble que pour la
candidate du rassemblement national
c'est un élément de communication mais l
art fair dire répété hier encore sur
france info et côté on les connaît ils
sont soumis à de véritable chantage si
vous donnez pas si vous donnez votre
parrainage à untel untel untel et bien
on ne vous donnera pas les subventions
c'est vrai d'un s'attendre de
département qui font ça c'est vrai d'un
certain nombre de communautés
d'agglomération de communes ces mêmes
devrait semble-t-il d'un saddam de
conseils régionaux donc ils ont cette
crainte or comme le fait de parrainer et
que leurs noms soient rendus publics
leur fait craindre des rétorsions de la
part de d'élus politiques qui ne serait
pas en accord avec la personne qu'il
qu'il paraît eh bien ils sont de moins
en moins nombreux à le faire alors
est-ce qu'il ya ou pas des pressions
contre les maires pour qu'ils ne votent
pas qui ne parraine pas pardon le
rassemblement national marine le pen ou
jean luc mélenchon c'est à vous nous le
dira mais évidemment pour elle c'est
bien sûr une stratégie de communication
toujours dans la dédiabolisation de son
parti bien qu'elles partent cette fois
sans étiquette partisane cécile gallien
vous êtes maire d'une petite commune
vous l'avez rappelé moins de 2000
habitants est ce que vous êtes souvent
sollicités on a reçu tous les
parrainages donc enfin peut-être pas
tous puisque il en manque évidemment
certains ne se sont pas encore déclarés
les maires je pense la majorité des
maires n'ont pas tellement envie de ses
tics t politiquement
il faut le dire ces bonnes je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit à nouveau un faut
rappeler quand même que les personnages
sont rendus publics par le conseil
constitutionnel
si mais par contre ce que je voudrais
dire c'est quand même c'est quand même
dommage que je alors être sans doute ya
peut-être des pressions de ses chantage
à la subvention c'est pas une histoire
uniquement de période présidentielle ça
peut exister par ailleurs donc je n'ai
rien dit non ce que je voulais dire par
là c'est que je pense que dans cette
france il faut que les élus entre eux
acceptent d'avoir des philosophies
politiques différentes et que c'est ça
la richesse de la france c'est aussi
permettre
à des idées différentes de s'exprimer eh
ben on va terminer là dessus c'est un
bon message de fin merci beaucoup merci
à tous d'avoir participé à cette
émission depuis
le congrès des maires de france public
sénat partenaire du congrès des maires
de france je rappelle le titre de vos
livres stéphane le foll vous publiez
renouer avec la france des lumières
c'est chez calmann lévy martial foucault
maire au bord de la crise de nerfs la
démocratie locale peut-elle survivre
c'est aux éditions de l'eau